es ist gerade sechs uhr 45 gibt
definitiv entspannter uhrzeiten um seine
weisheitszähne raus zu bekommen ja ihr
habt richtig gehört freunde jetzt gleich
werde ich zum chirurgen fahren und werde
alle vier weisheitszähne raus bekommen
alter mir wird jetzt erst bewusst was
das eigentlich für eine kranke aktion
als nächstes jahr auf dem beifahrersitz
meine mutter fährt gerade weil danach
darf man erst mal kein autofahrer
eigentlich wo ich das jetzt gar nicht
filmen durch hat mit den letzten tagen
noch so viele videos angeguckt die leute
ihre weisheitszähne raus bekommen und
danach sind die halt so komplett
irgendwie aus dem leben geschoss
deswegen fahren wir jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal dahin
es ist jetzt gerade 57 ich habe den
termin in zehn minuten tatsächlich wir
sind beim kieferchirurg wir sind beim qi
verzierungen angekommen also ich mich
jetzt gleich wenn wir drin sind mit
myphone wieder hallo jetzt lukas als
zukunft die szene die er gerade gesehen
hat war am mittwoch um 8 uhr kurz vor
der op en jetzt gerade ist freitag 14
und ich habe die ganze sache schon
hinter mir ich durfte drin beim
kieferchirurgen jedoch nicht vor der op
und auch nicht während der op film das
heißt die nächsten aufnahmen die es wert
sind nach der op mit meinem iphone
entstanden falls ihr euch gleich fragt
wie soll ich mich in den nächsten szenen
so beschied anhöre oder so benebelt
benehmen
das sind die nachwirkungen des mittels
was ich bekommen habe damit ich von der
operation nichts mitkriegen und auch
schon mal sorry für die dummen
kameraaufnahmen aber meine mutter hat
gefilmt und ihr werdet jetzt sehen dass
sie das nicht kann
ich habe beim besten willen keine ahnung
was ich da an wollte er werden
so dauert und man durch ein kinder schon
relativ gut waschen war schön wieder
einmal
ja ich war schon hart aber dann hab ich
da auf jeden fall noch so 10 15 minuten
gechillt und meine mutter meinte er
versucht doch mal jetzt aufzustehen geht
nicht geht nun nicht mehr aufstehen habe
ich da noch nicht hingekriegt dann habe
ich halt noch ein bisschen gechillt hat
noch die bundes- ein bisschen nach
gekürt von dem ist euch vorstellen dass
einer weisheitszahn op wird halt der
komplettem und betreut wenn man kriegt
quasi vier zähne raus werden
herausgeschnitten und so und ist ja
logisch dass man da quasi betreut wird
auf jeden fall spürt man in der zeit
danach auch die lippe und so was alles
gar nicht mehr so richtig und ich habe
mir beim nachfüllen geführt 40.000 mal
richtig doll auf die lippe gebissen und
was das hervorgerufen hat das seht ihr
jetzt ja meine mom war abgefuckt von mir
auf jeden fall als sieger mit dem auto
vorgefahren und hat mich abgeholt und
jetzt sitze ich quasi wieder im auto
die story geht weiter
[Musik]
überschreitet lassen war darunter
vorstellen
[Musik]
in der komischen wattebäuschen hat
also ich bin jetzt seit eineinhalb
stunden wieder hier gerade geschlafen
die betäubung lässt so langsam so ein
bisschen nachricht über das radio
wattebäuschen draußen kann ich deswegen
kann ich schon relativ gut wieder reden
ich habe jetzt gerade noch keine hamster
button glaub ich also ich hab es nicht
ein spiel geguckt aber du meinst dass
gerade aber morgen angeblich also ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns wieder und ich
lasse mir noch ein bisschen
das heute 17 uhr ich glaube jetzt gerade
noch ein paar stunden hier im bett meine
mutter wir oben bisschen eintopf püriert
ich mein eindruck ist schon relativ
scheiße und dann auch noch kuriert ist
ein besonders heißer auf jeden fall wird
es schon dunkel draußen und ich habe
eigentlich noch nichts geschafft heute
aus so dass ich wirklich nur will
da kann die dort blut aus der wunde
erstmalig soll eigentlich gar nicht
dieser schwester für eltern eigentlich
sollte ich gar nicht reden und nicht nur
schon weil sonst die schmerzen den
nächsten tagen nur noch schlimmer werden
also würde ich sagen halte ich jetzt auf
jeden fall meine fresse und wir sehen
uns jetzt quasi am nächsten tag morgen
wieder und schauen wie es mir danken ich
erschreckend freuen das ist gerade fünf
uhr 26 in der nacht ist der andere leute
waren in der nacht nach der
weisheitszahn op sooo auf wegen
irgendwelchen schmerzen den pocher
anlegen eigentlichen kühlakkus tiefer
rutscht sind ich bin gerade aufgewacht
weil ich die übelsten hunger hatte das
bin ich für ein mensch auf jeden fall
strafe jetzt noch mal ein paar stunden
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
hell ist und ich wieder wach
es ist jetzt gerade 11 37 ich habe jetzt
gerade noch gepennt habe ich ein
bisschen ausgeruht
die banken sind bei mir irgendwie
komplett in ordnung ich habe die
komplette nacht gestern halt noch durch
gekühlt mit kühlwesten habe jetzt gerade
noch eine eu genommen obwohl ich
eigentlich gar keine schmerzen habe ich
sagt halt wirklich dass sie in diesem
video jetzt meine amt verpackung so
richtig sieht und das ist so richtig
bescheuert aus dem gar nicht richtig
sprechen kann aber irgendwie bin ich
topfit
also ich gehe jetzt erstmal duschen
ich habe jetzt gerade geduscht
ich habe immer noch keine hamster backen
ich habe keinen wirklichen schmerzen
obwohl ich die letzte irgendwie vor 13
14 stunden genommen habe
die op ist jetzt mehr als 30 tonnen her
also kann das bei mir immer irgendwie
kommen oder so versteht mich bitte nicht
falsch ich bin sehr froh darüber dass
ich keine schmerzen habe dass ich keine
dicken hans verbacken habe und so weiter
und so fort aber ich dachte einfach
dieses video könnte lustig werden
dadurch dass ich habe so backen habe und
ich reden kann
aber ich merke dass ich wieder blutet
lud ich glaube ich werde mir jetzt
trotzdem noch mal ein kühler co hier rum
schneiden die beste film oder zurück ich
lass das jetzt mal ein bisschen noch mal
den kopf gebunden wechsel das dann jetzt
stündlich aus und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns dann wieder wenn die sonne
untergegangen ist also heute abend sechs
stunden später habe ich jetzt
tatsächlich noch immer keine schmerzen
ich spiele gerade fifa
ich habe die komplette noch ohne
erhöhungen ohne kühlakkus geschlossen
und das war doch alles wie es ist jetzt
gerade genau das 21 ich bin aufgewacht
hatte so ein bisschen blut im mund meine
wangen taten total wer also wenn er
irgendwas weiß jetzt hier raus bekommen
sollte und nach 24 stunden oder 36
stunden noch immer keine schmerzen hat
gerne hamster backen keine nachblutungen
keine ahnung was kühl trotzdem weiter
ich habe den fehler gemacht uns nicht
gemacht
jetzt sind wir wieder hier in der
gegenwart angekommen die schmerzen die
ich heute morgen nach dem aufstehen
hatte waren eigentlich primär dadurch
bedingt dass ich ohne erhöhung
beschlagnahmten mein kiefer sich quasi
sondern so ein bisschen so um geschoben
hat und dadurch kam ich habe schon
wieder blut geschmack dadurch kamen
eigentlich hauptsächlich die schmerzen
zustande
also das hat sich jetzt alles wieder
geregelt das heißt ich habe eigentlich
noch immer keine hamster backen ich habe
keine richtige schmerzen durch die
weisheitszähne meine mutter hat mir auch
gerade schon am und geguckt und meinte
das ist relativ gut alles schon verheilt
nur ich habe immer mal ab und zusammen
blut geschmack als ihr eure
weisheitszähne raus bekommen solltet ihr
noch ein paar tipps
ich habe mich vorher total verrückt
gemacht weil leute zu mir meinte danach
hast du total schmerzen und keine ahnung
war es bei mir war gar nix also ich bin
topfit ich hatte jetzt nie wirklich
irgendwelche kassen schmerz und keine
hamster machen ich habe noch einmal
zugenommen was ich euch also empfehlen
kann es euch einfach nicht verrückt
machen vor der op und vor allem nach der
op müsste halt sehr viel schmerzmittel
nehmen und antibiotika damit keine
entzündung auftritt ich kann mich nur
dass hier empfehlen
ich bekomme dafür kein geld aber ich
will euch noch tipps geben wie ihr euren
körper helfen können das ist ein
nahrungsergänzungsmittel und das hilft
quasi eurem marken und da quasi nochmals
arbeiten war durch die ganzen
medikamente et cetera schmerzmittel ist
der halt voll drauf ich würde sagen wir
fragen jetzt aber auch noch mal meine
mutter wie sie mich nach der op
wahrgenommen hat
3,0 für mich ja dann gar nichts mehr
erinnern wie ich von dem auf wachzimmer
ins auto überhaupt gekommen bin ich
immer gedacht ich hätte mit trockenen
braucht gut
wer nicht will ist nicht so wie youtube
oder das ist aber hier auch vom video
meine damen und herren es tut mir leid
dass ich mich jetzt nicht so mit fetten
hamster backen gesehen habt oder
blutüberströmt ok blut habt ihr gesehen
aber das habe ich zensiert weil ich
angst vor +18 habe und so bin ich auf
der sicheren seite laut youtube
wir brauchen falls euch dieses video
gefallen hat also ein bisschen eine
mischung aus block aber trotzdem so real
talkshow riet ein bisschen interview mit
meiner mom so ein bisschen recap mäßig
dann würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
leichter lassen schreibt mal in die
kommentare op
wenn ihr das video wirklich bis zum ende
geschaut hat und sonst würd ich sagen
meine damen und herren kommen wir jetzt
zu einer szene auf die man sich glaube
ich wirklich die ganze zeit schon freud
und zwar das auto rollte auf das was das
team vom bio das war es jetzt hier vom
video hier können jetzt jeden kanal
abonnieren oder
meinen shows checken jetzt findet ihr
zwei andere videos und wenn ihr sohn
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]